elle est à la mode en
chantier ouvert par françois hollande le
redécoupage de la france un compromis
aussi délicat à trouver que sur le pacte
de responsabilité la ministre de la
réforme de l'état de la décentralisation
et de la fonction publique et donc
l'invitée de preuves par 3 bonsoir
marylise lebranchu merci d'être avec
nous pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec perrine tarneaud ou de la fp avec
thierry masure ce soir et de dailymotion
les résistances s'exprime déjà si
fortement parmi les élus à qui on
annonce donc la simplification du
coûteux millefeuille territorial que
l'on peut se demander si cette réforme
ne restera pas un voeu pieux non pas du
tout d'abord il faut prendre acte du
succès d' du vote de la première loi moi
je suis toujours étonné que on ne se
félicite pas d'être passé d'un texte qui
pouvait être difficile à la création des
métropoles mais aussi au grand paris que
tout le monde attendait depuis longtemps
s'est fait
sur cette impulsion donnée président de
la république a décidé non seulement
qu'il fallait continuer et il fallait
monter une marche qui a redonné une
impulsion pour que on se retrouve ici
elle a quelques mois puisque on
commencera au sénat où nous sommes on
est une loi qui dise clairement les
compétences de chacun qui fait quoi qui
referme un peu plus ses compétences
pense au développement économique à la
formation professionnelle de transport
mais c'est donc ça c'est un big bang et
certains se dit ça va faire pschitt
comme ça ça va faire pschitt on est en
train déjà décrire la loi j'ai rencontré
quelques parlementaires jeu projet
proposé à tous les groupes d'aller les
rencontrer vois ça peut faire ce petit
pas ce que vous avez dit je ne vais pas
manier la jambe alors qu'est-ce qu'elle
l'outil vous reste-t-il marylise
lebranchu pourquoi j'ai écouté les plus
hostiles de vos amis voient le scalpel
ça va être long mais c'est l'année
dentelle c'est trop facile une loi pour
qu'elle soit appliquée doit être voté
par le parlement nous ne sommes pas en
dictature et c'est tant mieux donc pour
avoir une loi votée par le mois
parlement il faut donner des choses
claires aux parlementaires c'est quoi
une compétence exclusive comment réduit
le nombre de schémas régionaux pour en
faire un vrai schéma du développement
économique de l'innovation et de la
meilleure jargon attention nombre ont un
vrai schéma qui s'impose aux autres
collectivités territoriales comment le
citoyen en fait tu vas pouvoir ensuite
venir avec nous savoir où il s'adresse
pour tel ou tel type d'intervention
garde et de la solidarité parce que les
français sont attachés à la solidarité
et faire que nos communes avec nos
intercommunalités
rationalise aussi en moi l'envié
d'écrire à sa berline en simple sur un
sujet assez complexe quel est pour vous
le nombre idéal de région tu ne sais pas
quel est pour vous le nombre idéal de
départements sans doute beaucoup moins
qu'aujourd'hui mais je n'ai pas fait le
calcul mouillez-vous sais c'est pas
mathématique qu'un bref un an mais
quelle va être votre base de réflexion
est ce que ça va être les économies
réalisées est ce que vous avez fixé un
objectif budgétaire non j'ai pas les
objectifs budgétaires mais la résultante
sera intéressant pour moi j'ai un
objectif c'est clarifier les conséquent
les compétences par d'accord avec comme
conséquence bien évidemment des
économies du côté de l'état du côté des
régions du côté des départs il en parle
en milliards d'euros d'accords pour
l'idée c'est de supprimer les doublons
les compétences 500 films en arrêtant de
se regarder comme si on était une
horreur alors même que rappelons-nous
les landes der allemand auquel il est
toujours fait différent références ont
été obligés de créer des espèces d'ânes
ex deux länder qui correspondent à peu
près à nos départements donc restons
calmes sur les comparaisons nous sommes
nous ne sommes pas si mal
à condition d'être plus clair plus
transparent aussi sur les compétences et
en particulier sur le développement
économique parce que c'est ça qui
attendent les français mais qu'on est
aussi une compétence solidarité de
proximité parce que c'est ça aussi tu es
tu en es français en difficulté etc
enfin puisque nous gardons notre nombre
de communes nous puissions impulser les
fusions
commercer sans rien changer il y aura
bien quand même des changements
importants à la commune il y aura des
fusions d'intercommunalités il y aura
des fusions département il y aura des
fusions de région et une fois vous
prépare le chiffre est encore une fois
cette première étape passée par
incitations et comprime financière parce
que j'ai des élections en 2015 et que je
n'ai pas le droit de diminuer mon nombre
de régions à vendre 1015 compte tenu des
élections ensuite je mets entre 2015 et
ce sera applicable aux 2020 au moment
des nouvelles municipales alors vous
aurez non c'est pas du tout alors ça
sera juste après les élections
régionales vous allez avoir quelques
régions en moins une réorganisation
pourquoi je ne fusionne pas des régions
tout de suite parce que j'ai déjà des
frontières régionales et au lieu de
fusionner deux régions peut-être cafard
que j'en coupe donc c'est pas si facile
à faire quand les durs de les disloquer
certaine on voit les résistances qui
s'expriment parmi la population la
prévention car dit par exemple touche
pas à ma picardie mais on pourrait
prendre tellement d'exemples la seconde
et ce sont les élus qui freinent cette
attention la population est attachée y
compris à ces départements rappelez vous
du débat sur les plaques minéralogiques
comme on a été surpris donc ce qu'il
faut c'est être efficace que m'a demandé
le premier ministre ce que m'avait
demandé déjà quelques heures avant le
président de la république qui gère
directement le dossier il à dire
enfin il ne peut pas écrire la loi le
prix mais les impulsions en plus j'ai la
chance d'avoir un premier ministre et
après dans un public qui sont totalement
passer votre chance sans son accord
alors aussi contre vous j'ai envie de
dire certains de vos amis politiques je
le disais le président de l'association
des régions de france le socialiste
alain rousset qui préside l'aquitaine
dénonce une vieille idée technocratique
le présidentialisme
sur la suppression de certaines régions
par agiles ou puissants dresser le
président des départements claudy
lebreton socialiste également lui met en
garde contre l'exercice périlleux que
vous lancez ses mots sur les risques je
prends des risques parce qu'il ya un
moment donné faut prendre des risques
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile à faire
la tâche n'est pas simple mais moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est que avec un
dossier qui est compliqué je sorte avec
une loi qui soit claire pour les
citoyens et je pense que les citoyens
veulent par exemple s'ils sont en
recherche d'emploi ou quelqu'un de leur
famille à recherche d'emploi canet kad
qui soit responsable du parcours qu'on a
à faire si une entreprise a besoin de
formation professionnelle il y en a
qu'un qui serait responsable de la
formation dont elle a besoin une
entreprise qui veut des aides directes
n'aura qu'un qui pourra lui donner en
revanche parfois un centre de recherches
pourraient être aidés aussi par une
métropole d'accord c'est pas
inintéressant donc conjuguer des efforts
quand il en est besoin avoir un
interlocuteur unique
quand il n'est pas besoin de conjuguer
des efforts et avec tout ça on sera plus
serein plus apaisée et sans doute qu'on
regardera aussi la fiscalité soit plus
économe on sera plus économe on
regardera la fiscalité parce que je
pense que ce qui ne marche pas bien en
france aujourd'hui c'est l'inégalité
entre les territoires j'ai besoin de
territoire fort métropole région j'ai
besoin aussi que l'ensemble des
territoires de france occupent non
seulement des citoyens qui habitent mais
aussi de l'économie agricole agro
alimentaire par exemple pour reprendre
l'exemple un grand show de soieries
département de la banlieue il faut les
fusionner là vous êtes d'accord lors
d'une seconde de l'assemblée nationale
je me suis engagé à faire une étude de
faisabilité de cette fusion donc si
j'avais pas été d'accord et je rappelle
que c'est le premier ministre m'avait
donné l'autorisation de le faire donc
nous sommes entièrement d'accord vous
avez dit que votre arme donc ça ne sera
pas là mais ce sera l'incitation
financière donc un bonus malus
financiers c'est-à-dire la carotte et le
bâton
oui mais oui c'est toujours malheureux
de dire ça parce qu'on a l'impression
que les élus ne fonctionne que comme ça
je crois qu'en france il ferait aussi
parce que ça éviterait la tentation de
certains extrême qu'on réhabilite nos
élus ils sont pas laxistes ils sont pas
gaspilleurs ils font pas n'importe quoi
en revanche quand ils ont la compétence
sur tout et qu'un citoyen leur demande
les pousse à faire ceci ou cela ils le
font donc de dans leur aussi les moyens
de pouvoir dire non un certain nombre de
cofinancement et ceux qui demandent
aujourd'hui
que ce soit plus clair parfois vont se
réveiller durement parce qu'untel ou
untel ne pourra plus les aider donc
donnons les moyens aux élus d'être
encore plus efficace ils en ont les
moyens les moins jeunes ont envie faire
parce qu'ils en ont trop eu déjà des
années
diriez vous dites qu'ils se surpassent
pilleurs mais ce qu'ils ont pu se rendre
coupables de mauvaise gestion quand on
voit par exemple vous allez pouvoir
peut-être que confirmer ou infirmer je
ne sais pas l'explosion du nombre de
fonctionnaires territoriaux dans les
régions par exemple mais qui ne sont pas
tous justifiés pour cent des transferts
de compétences mais ça c'est pas tout à
fait certain parce qu'on en oublie
toujours que la gestion des tos a obligé
les régions à créer des services
d'accompagnement de ce doc perçoivent
ces personnels non enseignants des gens
bien pensants a d'ailleurs en convient
aujourd'hui qu'on aurait pas dû confier
sa région parce qu'elle était d
administration de mission et pas de
gestion mais regardons aussi sur les
intercommunalités on me dit il ya plus
de personnel oui on s'est occupés
d'environnement s'en occupait pas avant
de déchets on s'est occupé aussi de
créer des services à la personne de
petite enfance de halte-garderie y
compris dans nos communes rurales donc
effectivement on a créé les services
publics et moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de savoir que le service public est
utile que le service public est efficace
mais que le service public n'est pas
redondant dire qu'il n'y a pas de
doublon y compris avec les services
alors il ya un élu qui est par ailleurs
patron de partie c'est jean françois
copé lui pour positif des choses toutes
simples on supprime dit-il purement et
simplement les départements et on les
fusionne avec les régions et il propose
en passer par un référendum voilà une
solution simple mais c'est simple et
c'est simpliste je suis désolé parce que
on lui dit il chiffre les économies le
nom alors huit chiffres milliards d'eur
milliards il ya une grande étude
chiffrée à venir il ya kpmg qui dit ça
coûte 6 milliards au début ça coûte plus
cher au début ce qui se passe c'est que
quand on chiffres pour les départements
ont chiffré leurs compétences
obligatoires et leurs compétences
obligatoires par exemple les
départements aide une commune ça ne suit
pas disons non à un fictif si l'école à
brûler le département va aider la
commune alors ça c'est pas comptés dans
les dépenses de départements d'ici on
supprime les départements je supprime
cette dépense non je la transfert c'est
pas la même chose donc je pense qu'il
faut être extrêmement sérieux rigoureux
et prénom est prudent parce que regarder
l'action sociale
nos personnes âgées et aux personnes en
situation de handicap les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi vous supprimez le
département vous avez deux hypothèses le
transfert soit c'est l'état soit scellé
commune une commune qui a très peu de
moyens pourra-t-elle
rendre service à ces personnes âgées non
parce que je ne sera pas mutualiser le
département était une source de
solidarité soyons prudents mais efficace
c'est pas un tract politique c'est de
l'action politique avec deux petites
questions on a beaucoup glosé sur le
virage de françois hollande même sur son
revirement se renie membres après sa
conférence de presse vous avez entendu
tous les commentaires est-ce que ça
n'est pas le cas sur le sujet qui nous
occupe marylise lebranchu puisque la
gauche revenait au pouvoir avait
supprimé la fusion lancé par nicolas
sarkozy des élus départementaux et
régionaux et là c'était une source
d'économie vous êtes marche arrière et
en fusionner les élus mais je vous
rappelle ont fusionné pas les
institutions première étape ah bon
c'était déjà une contrée par source
d'économie je ne sais pas parce que
quand vous fusionnez les élus comme
netto co obligé de reconstruire tous les
tous les hôtels de région pour
accueillir tous les élus de tous les
départements parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
de place on savait qu'on réduise et en
réduisant leur nombre oui mais on était
au-dessus 87 en montagne on devait
passer à 125 alors autre chose non on
fusionnait pas les institutions l'idée
c'est d'avoir quand c'est possible y
compris des fusions d'institutions mais
regardez l'alsace c'est facile à dire
tout ça on fait un référendum et on
avait proposé la fusion de la région des
départements 10 à orly les citoyens
veulent des fusions résultat ils ont
voté contre alors donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut il ne faut plus faire appel
au peuple demain pour les fusions de
collectivités territoriales de même rang
les régions les départements les
communes ou les intercommunalités ne
suis pas favorable effectivement au
référendum mais je pense qu'on peut
partir aux élections dangereux non c'est
pas dangereux moi je j'ai été un jour
candidate à une mairie j'ai voulu la
fusion je me suis présenté en disant je
veux la fusion et la commune d'à côté
j'ai perdu parce que la commune d'à côté
à voter contre la fusion mais je pense
qu'on peut partir dans une élection
disant jeu je me présente à tel niveau
je souhaite telle fusion alors
paradoxaux le peuple dira d'ailleurs
paradoxe encore vous aviez rétabli c'est
pas vieux
lowe's de compétence générale qui donne
en fait aux collectivités locales balaie
les mêmes pouvoirs quoi elles font ce
qu'elles veulent un donc hélas la bière
établie elle avoue nous dit aujourd'hui
il faut clarifier mais pourquoi ce
changement de pied mais je pense que
séoul c'est un mea culpa coup on a envie
d'entendre non parce que moi j'ai écrit
ça
dans la mission lambert où il ya quelque
temps elle était interviewé omd est ce
que vous êtes favorable à la clause de
compétence générale c'était non donc la
véritable et on est partis tel constat
de défiance totale entre les états et
enfin 3 le gouvernement et les élus
défiance tels que on a vu beaucoup de
collectivités territoriales se replier
le président de la république et je
rétabli la confiance je regarde avec
vous comment on peut faire je tire
maintenant je suis en 2014 je tire le
son du vote de la première loi le vote
de la première loi me montre que sur les
métropoles vous êtes plutôt favorable a
par exemple sur paris une disparition
des départements vous m'avez demandé au
1er janvier 2017 les conventions
obligatoire je rappelle entre les
départements et les métropoles donc vous
parlement de france vous avez fait
avancer beaucoup le dossier mois
président de la république au premier
ministre à côté puisqu'ils ont la même
avis je vous propose de continuer sur
cette lancée et de renforcer la
régionalisation d'accord et d'avoir
moins de compétences partagées et comme
nous avons déjà créé la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique un
lieu de discussion et bien nous avons
l'outil pour avancer nous avons donc
avancé et l'énergie on vous entend
marylise lebranchu l on va voir
maintenant comment vous allez vous y
prendre pour faire des économies dans la
fonction publique et là ce sont plus les
élus ce sont les syndicats que vous
affrontez une certaine manière avant
d'accueillir tirer mesure de l' agence
france-presse le point sur un chantier
social délicat sinon explosif avec
mounir souci
j'estime qu'il est possible de faire des
économies
nombreuses tout en préservant notre
modèle social fort de cette conviction
françois hollande espère économiser 50
milliards d'euros d'ici la fin de son
quinquennat une cure d'amaigrissement
qui aura des conséquences sur la
condition des cinq millions et demi de
fonctionnaires leurs salaires et
retraites représentent près de 40% des
dépenses publiques le gouvernement est
face à une équation compliquée
comment économiser sans baisser les
salaires tout en créant des postes dans
l'éducation et la sécurité il ne reste
plus beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre pour
parvenir à cet objectif
c'est à dire qu'il faut au gouvernement
soit continuer le gel du point d'indicé
qui a été initiée en 2010 ou bien
continuer de rogner sur les mesures
catégorielles les primes des
fonctionnaires
marylise lebranchu évoque une éventuelle
fin du gel des salaires avant 2017 une
mesure coûteuse la hausse d'un point
d'indicé représenterait 8 100 millions
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires
depuis l'arrivée de françois hollande à
l'elysée les syndicats négocient dans un
climat apaisé avec leur ministre de
tutelle mais il commence à perdre
patience le dialogue social s'il n'y a
pas de grain à moudre issia pas derrière
d'augmentation de salaire et des mines
jean des effectifs ça ne suffira pas
pour calmer les fonctionnaires et son
ras-le-bol augmentera encore plus à la
fin du mois de janvier tout simplement
parce que pour la première fois le
salaire des fonctionnaires va baisser
une exaspération dangereuse dans cet
électorat traditionnellement favorable à
la gauche en cette année électorale
beaucoup pourraient être tentés par le
front de gauche l'abstention
à moins que le gouvernement annonce une
mesure choc
le deal qui avait été proposé par le
passé c'était sans doute moins de
fonctionnaires mais mieux payés et sans
doute une voix qui à la fois père mènera
de contenter les fonctionnaires en place
et à la fois de mener à bien cette
réforme de l'état que tout le monde
appelle de ses voeux avant une
éventuelle sanction dans les yeux en le
ras-le-bol des fonctionnaires
s'exprimera dans la rue avec une grève à
l'appel de la cgt programmée le 6
février prochain
voilà thierry masure france et avec nos
territoires vos questions donc sur ces
sujets multiples relevant de la fonction
publique à la ministre on est en plein
dans l'actualité l'a donc la première
chose que j'ai envie de vous demander
demain matin et a le premier conseil
stratégique de la dépense publique qui
se tient autour de françois hollande
donc c'est le début des travaux publics
alors est ce que c'est la fonction
publique qui va être il est faux de les
fonctionnaires notamment qui vont se
retrouver sur le grill non d'abord c'est
vrai que par rapport à l'ancien
gouvernement n'était au moins trente
mille postes par an et on est à - 0
l'idée était de renforcer l'éducation
nationale parce qu'on a un vrai
challenge devant nous la police la
justice et l'emploi et puis bien
évidemment hamas constante ça veut dire
de supprimer des postes c'est vrai et je
comprends la colère des syndicats dans
d'autres secteurs la défense qui a donné
un beaucoup de postes merci la
forteresse comme on dit économie et
finances a participé et quelques uns ici
ou là donc on a sérié
ce nombre de postes à supprimer
aujourd'hui la feuille de route est
différente on continue effectivement la
trajectoire et syndicats vous disent on
est à l'os thierry le paon le disais
hier dans le monde dont l'état loos
alors comment va faire sur
l'administration territoriale de l'état
se dire sur les territoires c'est là que
le premier ministre me demande de faire
et fort avec l'ensemble de mes collègues
c'est ce dont on va être discutée
comment avoir peut-être un peu moins en
centrale et plus sur les télés moteur
d'effectifs la voie que nous donner un
chiffre en termes d'effectifs ça va
venir je ne suis pas favorable à de
neige quand même on a envie de savoir
mais ce sera combien j'anticipe jamais
sur les dossiers qui sont pas terminées
mais si vous savez que fait pas de
politique fiction mais je veux plus de
monde on est en train de faire une
analyse territoire par territoire y aura
moins un enfant du ministère par
ministère
je ne sais pas s'il y aura moins de
fonctionnaires mais il y aura peut-être
moins au niveau de l'état sur certains
postes plus haut niveau des
collectivités territoriales si on
transfère des compétences se traite
idiot de garder à nouveau des doublons
mais je voudrais dire parce que c'était
important moi je comprends ce que des
fonctionnaires 4 angel n'y a pas
beaucoup de
personnes salariées du privé qui ont
quatre ans vous reconnaissez qu'il on
perdu du pouvoir d'achat est en revanche
moi j'ai proposé et le premier ministre
a accepté on a augmenté les catégories c
c'est à dire les plus petits salaires je
pense que les plus hauts salaires s'en
sortent parce que ils ont un peu plus de
chance mais ils l'ont mérité bien
évidemment mais c'était sur les petits
salaires et en particulier dans la
fonction publique territoriale tout en
ayant conscience d'avoir fait aussi plus
de dépenses publiques pour les
collectivités territoriales
mais on a pris d'abord l'aspect petit
salaire maintenant on dépose tous en
2015 faire comment parce que est-ce que
vous avez continué ce gel pour la
cinquième année et continuer à faire des
économies parce que les 50 milliards il
faut bien les trouver quelque part je ne
sais tu pas l'hypothèse qui sera choisie
mais je vous rappelle et tout le monde
veut l'oublier parce que ces techniques
mais c'est pour moi hautement politique
qu'on a commandé un point zéro
d'inconnus qui s'appelle bernard pêcheur
on pose toutes les carrières de la
fonction publique sur la table on
regarde comment faire fonctionner mieux
tout ça avec des parcours professionnels
avec des passerelles entre les
collectivités territoriales avec
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
y compris pour nos seniors puisque l'on
augmente la durée du travail donc on
prend en compte nos seniors on a un
chantier de 18 mois ça ne se fait pas à
coude annonce ça se fait métier
fonctions par courriel vous tous et que
vous allez comme ça jouer à saute mouton
au dessus des journées d'action des
syndicats y en a une par exemple le 6
février bon vent des îles font des
crises et puis on continue conduit les
premiers ministres ont l'intention de
faire comme s'il n'entendait rien du
tout le sens attentif non seulement à la
qualité de la fonction publique à nos
fonctionnaires mais aussi à leurs
conditions de vie alors vous pouvez
désamorcer c'est à un moment donné il
faudra qu'on ait une vraie discussion
mais avec les syndicats je suis désolé
pas avec vous et pas ici pour dire est
ce que c'est un peu de points à 10 est
ce que c'est encore un peu plus at-elle
catégorie est-ce que je mets plus sur
les parcours professionnels in fine et
quand on aura fini le mandat à dire 2017
sur l'ensemble des parcours
professionnels on aura propres pour les
carriers on aura progressé pour nos
fonctionnaires il est hors de question
de régresser sinon on va les perdre or
on a besoin de fonctionnaires pour le
service public et de fonctionnaires de
qualité donc c'est tout allait rouler
compliqué j'ai un travail de dialogue
social complexe mais nos fonctionnaires
demandent quoi de la reconnaissance ils
n'ont pas eu souvent d'être mieux
traitée par les médias --y compris
parfois aussi par le chef de l'état
puisque le chef de l'état a dit que
l'état était trop lourd autre chaîne n'a
pas dit les fonctionnaires sont roland
les temps l'état et les fonctionnaires
l'ont pris pour eux non mais moi je le
prends pour chacun quitte en fonction le
prend pour soi est ce que ce que me
demande ma le président de la république
par exemple quand je fais le dis le nous
une fois pour les entreprises avec
pierre moscovici quand on fait les
simplifications pour l'usager quand ils
rentrent qui sait qu'il aura rendez-vous
qui n'aura absolument pas attendre ce
qui n'est pas le cas dans certaines
entreprises privées quand on fait des
simplifications de cet ordre là on est
moins lourd on est plus efficace et une
fine et on sera moins cher puisqu'on va
économiser du temps cadre donc était ce
matin au secrétariat général de la
modernisation de l'action publique qui
dit comment on va mieux utiliser le
numérique comment on va réagir les une
nouvelle culture tout ça va fonctionner
mais
j'entends que les fonctionnaires eux par
rapport à leurs mandants et puis il ya
des élections à la fin de l'année à
l'intérieur de notre fonction publique
pour leur représentativité eh bien ils
ont envie aussi d'avoir comme disait
l'intervenant tout à l'heure interrogés
du grain à moudre est-ce qu'ils sont pas
un petit peu désorienté finalement les
fonctionnaires est ce que ce soit pas
été plus simple de dire eh ben le gel
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux le gel du un
fonctionnaire sur deux n'est pas
remplacé
lorsqu'il part en retraite eh bien on
poursuit cette mesure parce que de toute
façon pourra pas faire autrement c'est
comme ça ce n'était pas juste parce que
c'est efficace sur certains territoires
vous n'aviez plus personne en termes de
contrôle de l'agroalimentaire pour
l'export par exemple plus personne et
dans ce cas là vous pouvez perdre des
marchés donc la france ne s'y retrouvent
pas plus personne pour des problèmes de
santé plus personne pour de la sécurité
routière attention il faut qu on ait un
équilibre sur les territoires dont moi
j'ai à travailler dur mais qui est
passionnant c'est comment effectivement
on a sur le territoire l'état garant
l'état protecteur mais l'état qui permet
le redressement économique
comment on a peut être moins dans
certaines fonctions qui ne sont plus
utiles peut-être mais comment on fait
tout ça en améliorant et parcours
professionnels de nos fonctionnaires qui
sont peut-être un petit peu archaïque
parce que le fonctionnaire au fond il
attend il sait que dans cinq ans il aura
t'elle avancement et que dans x années
laura telle autre il passera d'un grade
un échelon tout ça n'est pas
suffisamment percutant et moi je pense
qu'on est capable de faire beaucoup en
remettant toutes les carrières sur la
table et en travaillant je l' ai rappelé
tout à l'heure mais c'est important sur
nos fonctionnaires seniors quand un
fonctionnaire territorial court derrière
la benne et qu'il a passé 60 ans
l'efficacité de l'action publique n'est
pas au rendez vous ni pour lui parce
qu'on ne les respecte pas ni pour le
service rendu on a des tas de choses à
penser les surveillants de la
pénitentiaire partent très tôt et ce qui
pourrait faire autre chose après ils
sont intéressés à ce qu'on va faire est
ce qu'il faut faire
toujours la même la même barrière entre
ce qu'on appelle les actifs la police et
surveillants de la pénitentiaire
cette profession qui pourrait travailler
plus longtemps il y en a qui me
demandent à travailler certains très
bons mais ils n'ont pas de passerelle et
qu'est ce qu'ils font dans ces cas là et
bien kita police pour entrer dans le
privé comme surveillants sont mal payés
bref pas heureux comment on rend nos
carrières plus attractive comment on
crée des passerelles qui permettent aux
fonctionnaires d'être efficace
d'éventuellement travailler plus
longtemps s'ils sont dans une famille
recomposée avec des enfants jeunes bref
il ya un tas de travaux à faire pour nos
fonctionnaires et dans l'efficacité et
dans l'économie les fonctionnaires n'ont
pas envie qu'on dépense plus pour ils
ont envie d'être reconnue alors
reconnu comme un vecteur fort de la
république française c'est eux qui
parlent des valeurs républicaines c'est
eux qui portent la partialité c'est eux
qui portent la loyauté fonctionnaires
c'est un lien il est un exercice
sacerdotale est très fonctionnel moi je
pense que c'est autre chose on n'est pas
fonctionnaire j'avais c'est pas un
emploi ordinaire vous devez garantir les
valeurs républicaines y compris quand
vous sortez de votre boulot vous êtes
encore fonctionnel vous êtes encore en
présentant la république c'est pas rien
et je pense que ça doit être dit reconnu
der le premier ministre et a présenté
ses voeux à m jeudi prochain et j'espère
et j'espère que j'en suis persuadé leur
dira il ya un vrai sujet de
reconnaissance de ce qui s'appelait la
câlinothérapie les fonctionnaires
gardent leur feuille de paie parce que
pas seulement dans la mesure où j'ai me
suis engagé à poser toutes les questions
sans tabou avec les fonctionnaires dans
le dialogue social j'espère qu'on
aboutira à quelque chose qui peut être
passera par des conflits je ne je ne
pense pas que nos réalisations pouvoir
signer un accord à quel horizon sur le
carrière moi j'avais 10 18 mois on a
commencé en janvier c'est difficile il
fera qu on est d accord d'étape parce
que effectivement ils vont demander sans
doute des étapes on va voir avec eux
quelle étape sont souhaitées mais je
reste persuadé qu'en même que les
fonctionnaires les moins payés ont bien
reçu qu'on ait augmenté les catégories c
je sais qu'ils aient les problèmes
maintenant sur les bas des catégories
juste au dessus on a resserré les
chenaux reste qu'il faut je sais pas -
plafonner la rémunération supérieure
d'étape qui fait peur que leur rue
s'embrase à commencer par le 6 février
la rue s'embrasser c'est une grande
phrase
un conflit de l'aide de la fonction
publique ne me fera bien évidemment pas
plaisir c'est évident je ne sais pas si
vous êtes démunis pour le désamorcer je
ne suis pas certaine de ça parce que
dans le dialogue social j'ai en face de
moi des gens extrêmement responsables
qui veulent dire à un moment donné au
peuple français aux citoyens français
pardonnez moi qui veux dire aux citoyens
français on est là et aujourd'hui c'est
nous qui payons la rigueur moi je hais
ce que j'adore décourager ça c'est pas
c'est pas bon non plus pour l'efficacité
de l'état opaque fonctionnaires seraient
découragés mais vous savez quand à
longueur d'antenne de lecture ils
entendent parler qu'ils sont une entrave
en fait à la bonne santé des
entrepreneurs par exemple et que les
entrepreneurs vers le ver leur demander
aide pour trouver un terrain à m pour
l'assainissement aide pour les déchets
être pour la localisation est pour
l'export elle pour les infrastructures
quelquefois ils sont découragés et sont
découragés parce que quand il demande à
l'entretenir mais pourquoi vous vous
pensez que je suis inutile
l'entrepreneur l'hymne pas vous mais
voilà une espèce d'imagerie collective
la fonction publique serait inutile non
la fonction publique est utile au
développement de la france et au
redressement de la france à condition
qu'on sait sur quelle mission et comment
voilà pourquoi c'est un challenge
difficile oui c'est la deuxième langue
officielle non mais c'est vrai la
réforme de l'état vous avez très bien
c'est pas la réforme du millefeuille
territorial
l'action publique du 21e siècle personne
ne peut plus ravis que moi merci thierry
masure une question encore sur la cgt en
a cité thierry le paon
qui appelle donc à cette mobilisation
des fonctionnaires et qui considèrent
que le premier ministre aujourd'hui de
la france c'est pierre gattaz
c'est sans doute une boutade c'est comme
si je disais moi le chef de tous les
syndicats c'est thierry bonjour thierry
saniez que lui dont je crois que de
temps en temps attention une boutade il
argumenté dit vous savez tout simplement
fait la politique du medef ça c'est
quand même pas vrai parce que si le
gouvernement faisait la politique du
medef en particulier sur ce que tous
viennent tout ce que je viens de dire la
fonction publique ce serait beaucoup
plus simple ils m'ont supprime rien sur
deux trois bars et puis on parlerait on
passerait à l'étape suivante je pense
que c'est plus complexe et plus
difficile que ça allait perrine tarneaud
de public sénat arrive maintenant pour
la troisième partie de cette émission
marylise lebranchu où nous parlerons de
la gauche du ps a apparemment sans voix
d'ailleurs comme votre grande amie
martine aubry marie brémaud
au sein de la majorité en ce moment on
ne parle plus de virages mais bien
d'accélération social démocrate comme si
l'économie de l'offre avait toujours été
à l'ordre du jour pour les socialistes
même l'ailé gauche du ps se fait très
discrète la gauche du parti peut ne pas
être content mais n'a pas grand chose à
proposer en et charge la politique qui
suivrait sa blonde d'un foudre de
d'insuffler de l'argent des noeuds dans
l'économie n'est pas suffisante pour
remédier aux problèmes structurels de
l'économie française les plus à gauche
tente de faire bonne figure et de sauver
la face c'est le cas notamment des
proches de martine aubry j'accorderai ma
confiance au gouvernement mais je ne la
corde raide dans la confiance et que si
il ya des contreparties sérieuses et si
on continue à mener une politique de
justice martine aubry qui ne partagent
pas les vues libérales du président de
la république lui exprime ses désaccords
mais là aussi en toute discrétion
vous savez il discute très régulièrement
ils le font loin des caméras parce que
martine aubry candidate aux municipales
ali lequel travaille dans son club en
essence à réfléchir à des idées
nouvelles et puis le président de la
république il est président de la
république donc chacun dans son couloir
chacun avec ses responsabilités chacun
avec son devoir d'avoir des résultats et
ça les empêche pas ensuite de s'échanger
très directement et très franchement sur
ce qui va et ce qui va pas mais ça il
souhaite pas le faire devant les caméras
les couloirs différents qui ne se
rejoignent pas souvent à chacun son
chemin voilà perrine tarneaud nous a
donc
madame la ministre est donc raté pour le
retour de martine aubry au plan national
est-ce que c'est raté pour son retour au
plan national ce virage social démocrate
c'est vrai j'avais parti c'est ça qui
m'étonne le plus on me dit elle est plus
là au niveau national sinon le plus beau
coup là elle est plus vocal parce
qu'elle vous voit pas mais
parisienne nationaux il n'est pas
forcément elle est très présente au
niveau local elles pas forcément utile
de parler aux médias sur pour avoir
toujours une influence politique d'hier
comme quand on rencontre le président de
la république le premier ministre des
ministres quand on râle sur telle mesure
quand on est en cours à acheter l'autre
quand on fait aussi moi j'ai bien aimé
cette respiration qu'elle nous a offerte
sur le prendre soin justement c'est quoi
l'action publique dans le prendre soin
de nos citoyens que partout le caire
elle n'est jamais parti mammeri quoi
concrètement la caisse qu'elle a connue
récemment comme inflexion on aimerait
savoir pourquoi voulez-vous que être en
politique ce soit être dans un
gouvernement il n'y a que trente et
quelques personnes c'est déjà beaucoup
c'est déjà beaucoup et puis certains
et en politique il ya beaucoup plus de
gens de que ça je pense que chacun peut
être utile là où il est ce qui est
important c'est pas qu'elle soit là sur
votre plateau peut-être
plaisir à mais nous on pense
effectivement à matignon comme le dit
michel ou à son retour des problèmes ils
sont avait pas de
quoi faire un remaniement voilà mais moi
j'en sais rien dire je suis pas dans la
tête du président la république
je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qu'elle quand
il y aura un remaniement s'il y en aura
un à quelle heure et puis si je dis que
le tournant social des modèles à sa
soeur de françois hollande est
compatible avec le positionnement
politique de martine aubry françois
hollande a tenu et c'était intéressant
dans les entretiens qu'on a en ce moment
parce que il ya aussi du travail c'est
ya cette notion de contrepartie
c'est-à-dire déquilibre aujourd'hui on a
quoi on a une crise et une sortie de
crise parce que la crise a commencé en
2008 qui est très lourde dans une sortie
de crise vous avez toujours
l'agroalimentaire après vous avez le
bâtiment enfin vous connaissez ça par
coeur donc on sait que ça va globalement
jusqu'en 2016 quand on lit les bonnes
études et pas ceux qui clament donc on
sait qu'il ya ça donc il s'engage
et prend au mot le patronat français qui
n'arrête pas de dire si nous ont des
bars moins vite que les autres c'est
parce que on paye trop de cotisations
banco payer moi une cotisation ils ont
déjà 4% - le rappelle donc ils vont être
transformés sans doute on verra le
résultat beaucoup s'envoler mais enfin
y'a pas d'objectif chiffré de la part du
chef de l'état peut importe je dire
quand les prend au mot en disant vous
vous dites que c'est leur être apportée
la responsabilité non le tournage non
pas du tout on est pro je ne fais pas
partie dans la réalité du chômage
d'entrepreneurs je vous dis colis si moi
je ne te parler contrepartie j'ai le
patronat dit si vous faites un geste et
en particulier sur les de la branche
famille et d'ailleurs il faut noter que
la cgt ou fo ont fait ce même cette même
type de proposition rappelons-nous et
bien nous créerons des emplois blanco on
y va sauf que en face il faudra
effectivement créer des emplois et que
le citoyen français
aura aussi le droit de martine aubry
pardon aura aussi tout moyen de
réfléchir à ce qu'on donne en terme de
baisse de cotisations et aux résultats
est ce que ces contreparties alors
vis-à-vis du medef il à vis du patronat
c'est ce qui va réussir à bâillonner
tenir la gauche du ps autour de ce pacte
de responsabilité
je pense que nul n'est bayonnais j'ai
entendu j'ai eu beaucoup de voix
discordantes à un vote de confiance à
pierre y ait un petit peu d'ordre oui
mais ce que je sens aujourd'hui ce que
je sais oui c'est que tout à chacun qui
est sur les territoires rencontre une
population qui veut que ça redémarre
sire que la france se redresse et c'est
vrai qu'un cent sans mettre à bas les
services publics par exemple ceux qui
m'ont travail sans mettre à bas y
compris nos collectivités territoriales
pour que l'accès à la culture par
exemple continue à permettre aux gens de
s'émanciper en pleine crise économique
mais ne demandent en même temps de
retrouver une france industrielle de
retrouver une france en europe et de
retrouver une france dans le monde or on
sait tous donc c'est le réalisme du
terrain la matinée terrain qui
l'emportent c'est l'analyse de la
situation et la volonté de faire face à
une période difficile mais on sait tous
par exemple que la chine qui a été
longtemps l usine à produire du monde
entier va commencer à acheter est ce
qu'on est prêt nous répond est ce qu'on
est prêt à créer de la valeur ajoutée en
france est ce qu'on est prêt à avoir
l'innovation que d'autres pays vont nous
demander ça c'est sur la table donc à la
corse ce qu'on a dit l'équivalent de la
branche famille ça a été annoncé un
accord une bonne organisation des
collectivités territoriales pour que
l'aide à l'innovation à la recherche
développement 1 transformation en
nurserie d'entreprise et j'en passe soit
au rendez vous et puis une à réaliser
contrepartie mais un service public qui
continue à exister c'est le modèle
français dire qu'on est en train de
sauver un modèle way avec une politique
de l'offre c'est difficile c'est
effectivement une ligne difficile mais
c'est une ligne et ça il faudrait est
fini il faudrait empêcher effectivement
les défections à gauche est ce que
l'autre contrepartie pour la gauche du
parti socialiste ce serait une petite
baisse des impôts pour les ménages en
2015 c'est pas une petite baisse des
impôts pour les ménages
ces escrocs demandent
comment je privilégie les catégories les
moins favorisés de mon pays sert comment
je garde un système social dead
important qui n'existe pas dans beaucoup
de pays comment effectivement sur
l'impôt je fais attention à ce qu'ils ne
sont en dessous des 2000 euros par mois
par exemple avec deux enfants qu'ils ont
vraiment payer l'impôt verront pas de
volonté de faire baisser les impôts pour
les ménages en 2015 ce qu'on ne peut pas
demander aux ménages et en particulier
aux plus faibles d'entre eux d'être ceux
qui vont permettre la baisse des
cotisations dont je viens de parler donc
c'est ça le la difficulté de ce
gouvernement c'est ça son châle en vient
on a privé quelle marge de manoeuvre on
n'a pris aucun chemin facile on appris
que des chemins difficiles mais parce
que la période est ainsi et que la
france dans l'eau je voudrais juste dire
une chose quand nous citoyens nous parle
ils sont aussi intéressés par ce que le
président de la république a obtenu un
smic en allemagne et l'accord et le spd
de martine aubry en juillet 2011
souvenez-vous martine aubry signons avec
sigmar gabriel ça c'est à fait important
nous citoyens de membres que pour la
directive des travailleurs détachés on
arrête de faire de la concurrence
déloyale et jean louis borloo louis vous
demande d'augmenter le smic aussi en
france c'est ce qui l'a demandé mais
c'est pas c'est pas à rejeter a priori
il ya des moments où il faut savoir
regarder ensemble c'est difficile mais
on y arrivera on y arrivera parce que la
france va se redresser et c'est ça qui
est important a dit en français quand on
emprunte un chien chômage déficit dans
des sûr de réussir à 100% non il faudra
il faut que le chemin est difficile mais
moi je j'ai tous les matins une part de
doute parce que celui qui est sûr
d'avoir raison à 100 % ne peut pas être
un politique ou alors il sa politique
qui peut être dangereux en revanche il a
toujours mais si on pouvait enfin parler
de la france avec un langage de
confiance je peux vous dire qu y compris
les tpe les pme les petites boîtes ne se
porterait pas de la même façon c'est le
sait le langage de défiance dans son
pays on appelle ça du bashing
c'est la défiance par rapport à son
propre pays qui amplifie la crise moi je
pense que le président de la république
a raison avec son premier ministre au
bout de 18 mois au bout de 18 mois moi
j'ai toujours eu l'impression d'être sur
scène lina bon peut-être que vous m'avez
pas écouté vous n'avez pas écouté
certains royal aurait reproché d'avoir
perdu deux ans non mais vous avez une
opposition mois l'opposition j'ai
entendu hurler en disant on ne parlait
pas d'héritage en février 2012 nous
n'étions pas au pouvoir depuis 2002
faisait dix ans il nous disait si on est
en difficulté c'est à cause de la gauche
donc peut-être que la voix y compris de
l'opposition pourrait devenir
raisonnables ce serait intéressant on
aurait un vrai débat quelques petites
questions politiques donc jean-louis
borloo il va soutenir le pacte de
responsabilité mais il ne votera pas la
confiance au gouvernement vous regretté
qu'il n'aille pas au bout de sa logique
charest jean louis borloo il fait ce
qu'il veut franchement je vais pas lui
demander de l'aide de quelques bons
centres seront utiles il ya des
défections à gauche
c'est pas comme ça il faut faire venir
on met sur la table la question on
mettra un document la meilleure un
document il n'est pas encore sur la
table à jean-louis borloo de prendre sa
décision d'accor et bayrou lui la rater
le virage social démocrate de françois
hollande il est parti trop tôt à droite
j'ai lu ça partout je pense qu'il a fait
un choix c'est le sien mais est ce que
les français attendent vraiment que
bayrou soit un peu plus ici ou un peu
plus là ils ont envie que ça fonctionne
mais je pense que si ça fonctionne
peut-être que bayrou viendra mais c'est
quand même pas moi je les aime beaucoup
ce garçon mais pendant ce temps
faire ce garçon j'aime bien françois
bayrou mais c'est pas mon sujet non
j'aime bien le rencontrer il est
intéressant parce que comme nous
journalistes vous avez senti lors de sa
conférence de presse mardi dernier que
françois hollande déjà en campagne pour
2010 est en campagne pour 2017 j'ai pas
senti ça mais je les trouvais bien en
sondant sa détermination et ça c'est
extrêmement agréable pour un ministre
que d'avoir et j'ai trouvé la même
source le premier ministre pour vous
j'ai trouvé qu'ils ont tous les deux ont
été une marge plus cirque avec des
étapes difficiles sont derrière nous
maintenant on voit là je sens on monte
les marches et j'ai moins envie de
monter les marches avec eux une derrière
eux parce que je suis derrière vous
l'avez sentiment là on y est et on a
beaucoup observé aussi par rapport à ses
tourments personnels jeu sam devaient
s'affairer à c'est pas parce qu'il est
temps de clarifier la situation
personnelle pas mon sujet la vie à
beaucoup de ses amis qui venant d'un
jeune ancien maire de tulle encore plus
intéressant vous parler de ma situation
personnelle chez moi tout va bien avec
moi
c'est ce que vous souhaitez aussi pour
françois hollande mais voilà mais chacun
il faut faire attention donc mais vous
faire attention aussi à la presse
internationale qui est très très dur
encore cette semaine justement sur
françois lachance notamment aux états
unis où il allait bientôt enfin la
chance c'est d'avoir malgré tout j'ai
envie de dire parce qu'effectivement je
pense que c'est pas simple pour lui en
tant que personne mais moi j'ai trouvé
un président serein et déterminé faisant
justement fi de ce qui est
de ce que sont ces premières occupations
personnelles moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt mal et je lui demande de rester
comme ça après pour sa vie personnelle
ça le regarde ce qu'est ce que vous
répondez à henri guaino qui déclarait ce
matin sur europe 1 françois hollande
demande tout ment tout le temps et
surtout c'est peut-être henri guaino nom
et fera une demande et j'ai pas qu'ils
nous illustre son propos qui face à joli
bouquin je sais pas sur la technique du
moins ce serait intéressant j'avais
envie de vous demander une dernière
question sur libé gs qui était utile de
rouvrir ce débat aujourd'hui je regrette
comment dire la réaction des bas moi ça
m'apparaissait normal j'ai envie de dire
presque naturel alors que le naturel
n'existe pas en droit qu'on enlève cette
clause qui a pu
encombrer le raisonnement et qui l'est
plus c'est au sein de détresse
c'est pas mon regret d'ailleurs c'est
qui est trop d'avortements jeu
c'est le même regret que celui de
marisol touraine où donner la tête
aujourd'hui à l'aube el kacem c'est
qu'on n'est pas assez bon et pas assez
tôt en particulier avec des plus jeunes
sur les situations de contraception la
contraception mais je pense qu'à ouvrir
certaines fractures qu'on est un jeu
bien entendu dans le pays notamment au
moment du texte sur le mariage ne sera
pas être hypocrite
pendant longtemps moi j'ai la chance des
plus âgés que vous c'est une chance
d'avoir vécu les premiers entretiens des
femmes qui demandait une ivg c'était
très dur et je pense que comme souvent
c'était en face des femmes elles n'ont
pas voulu continuer sur cette espèce de
concept de détresse qui est difficile à
partager en quoi l'arrivée d'un enfant
peut provoquer une détresse chez lui
n'est pas chez launay donc voilà je
crois qu'à un moment donné le respect de
l'individu forcé la loi il a forcé la
loi menant dans une semaine ce sera fini
sauf en espagne où certains s'inspirent
on cherchait un sport que ces villes en
france
et de tentations extrémistes y compris
là c'est une tentation d'extrémisme dia
fracturé les sociétés en fonction des
opinions souvent religieuses et je pense
que fracturé les sociétés en fonction
des opinions religieuses c'est chercher
une forme d'extrémisme ou d'intégrer et
c'est ouvrir la porte à deux nous sommes
interdits ce mal puisqu'aucun qui a
soutenu la manifestation je pense que
l'épiscopat français a raison de dire
qu'il est contre l'avortement parce que
c'est son engagement religieux mais il
n'a pas su tenir les médias allaient
manifester en tant que tel dehors c'est
autre chose je pense que la liberté
concernant l'arrivée j'ai livé j'ai la
liberté des femmes n'est pas une liberté
d'opinion c'est une liberté personnelle
liberté de son corps merci marylise
lebranchu merci perrine merci à tous bon
soir la semaine prochaine notre invité
sera brice hortefeux a très vite
on